final thoughts about brady okay brady
retired okay were you surprised when he
retired no not really yeah but you know
to me i think um i think it's good that
he did when he did i i hate to see when
guys
even switching teams i mean obviously he
won another one but
you know when they just kind of fade off
because they suck i think that's a
shitty way to go for a guy like that
same with you know joe montana or farv
or whatever it's like
when you see guys who are that good for
that long and he's i think the epitome
of that
uh i think it's better that he left when
he was kind of still on top yeah
charlemagne the god called him the
greatest athlete of all time
charlemagne the guy calling the great
like meaning better than michael yeah i
wouldn't call him the greatest athlete
of all time he's definitely the greatest
i would say he's the most successful
footballer the greatest football player
of all time but here's
what makes me a little upset here
imagine if michael jordan retired which
he did briefly but then and then he did
it again and he came back from the you
know came back to the washington wizard
let's just say he won a championship
with the wizards let's just say michael
jordan after everything he did with the
bulls and then he retired and all he did
was thank the wizards and the great
organization they had he was there for
two years he was there to the other team
patriots for 20 years and all he did was
thank the wizards you'd be saying dude
what are you talking about you were a
chicago bull through and through
legend and that's the way i i look at
tom brady dude
congratulations you you you
you're the man you you took
tampa bay that was nothing franchise for
decades and then you took him super
awesome but let's not forget
you're a patriot so obviously he's a
little salty from his exit whether
that's bob kraft whether that's a
belichick thing he's a little salty
about that but i i do think that bill
belichick had a very classy tweet or a
memo that i had out about brady
here's what my perspective is so let me
ask you a question so imagine you're
brady okay
and
you are making your mind whether you're
gonna retire or not you talk to your
wife you talk to your kids and you say
you know what
i wake up in the morning i'm retiring
okay
tell me the first five phone calls you
make before you're going to go public
give me the first five phone calls you
make other than your family yourself no
no you're not even even family you can't
tell everybody it's wife and i mean it's
immediate give me a five phone calls i
know where you're going with this it
needs to be the organization you're
retiring from first okay so perfect so
can we say
he probably is going to talk to bruce
charions
yeah
and and then after the coach
malcolm gladwell isn't that the owner
not malcolm gladwell
he doesn't have that kind of money but
the gladwell family i believe they own
this so so so you got so you got the
case you've got the coach who else is
going to call
do you think he's going to call anybody
from the patriots organization
no no he's not going to alert them at
all you so you don't think he calls
anybody you don't think he has a good
relationship with krause where he calls
him and say hey jerry listen i was with
you for now jerry cross you're talking
about i'm not jerry cross i'm talking
about uh uh robert cranston you know
tim's gonna call robert kraft and say
hey
you know here's where i'm at you don't
think he's gonna make a phone call like
that
he's definitely not gonna call that
relationship we know he's not gonna call
bill he's not gonna call well isn't it
um
bob kraft had decided not to resign him
two years ago in 2019 i don't know who
it was but uh is that belichick is he i
think he called a few people okay and
i'm thinking one of the people he called
is from new england patriots somebody
leaked the information to the news
everybody he called and he says tell me
you didn't say it
he believed four people the one person
that did say it he was so annoyed that
he says i'm going to snub you for my
recognition screw you guys i think
people like that are so
sensitive
to respecting them sharing private
information with you that if you cross
it they cross you i think it was that
simple i don't think it was i don't
disagree with you yeah i don't something
happened whether it was because
the fact that people leaked that he
wanted to be the one it wasn't official
for like 72 hours but i guarantee you it
was official
i guarantee you was official for 96
hours didn't he put something on social
media about it and before uh his team
knew he said in the interview no he
never did that he never did he he said
in the interview i'm going to talk about
and see what i'm going to be doing and
i'll get get back to you guys after he
lost but but put up belichick still is
belichick still here for me to read or
is it up there uh
he did in his in his instagram post do
you think the the obviously tampa bay
everything we just said he had one
reference to the patriots did you see it
he had one reference to the patriots
what was that he had a picture of him no
he's beating the patriots yeah beating
the patriots as a tampa bay buck this
year
so there was a subtle
so go down hand right there
i want to read here's what belichick
said i am can you make it a little
bigger so i can see it i'm privileged to
have drafted i am privileged to have
drafted that's a statement meaning i
picked you
i am privileged to have drafted
and coached tom brady the ultimate
competitor winner
tom's humble beginning in professional
football ultimately ended with him
becoming the best player in nfl history
tom consistently performed at the
highest level against competition that
always made him to number one player to
stop his pursuit of excellence was
inspirational tom was professional on
and off the field and carried himself
with some cl with class integrity and
kindness
i thank tom what a powerful word i thank
tom
for his relentless pursuit of excellence
and positive impact on me
that's a pretty humble statement writer
i thank tom
for his relentless pursuit of excellence
and positive impact on me
and the new england patriots for 20
years good for you how do you process
that though because you sounded a little
sarcastic about about which one about
belichick no no when i said i drafted
meaning
don't forget i
risked everything on you because i
believed in you 199. 198 people did not
i picked you
i believed in you never forget that one
you were nobody and i chose
when when drew bledsoe when you got a
hit
and your knee was gone and you were
dropped and we benched your second half
drew bledsoe came and won that game and
took us to the super bowl and i had two
weeks to decide and everybody from
willie mcginnis everybody said
belichick's gonna choose drew bledsoe as
a starting quarterback after having
signed a 100 million dollar contract
i made the announcement publicly and i
said tom brady will start the super bowl
and bledsoe in an interview was
devastated
and he says every every player
quarterback looks for this position to
be in to go into the super bowl
but uh it is what it is and you can see
the interview with bless how tough it
was for him
belichick chose
brady now imagine if he doesn't
you just can't you know there's you
can't you have to know that there is
there is some value there man that's
that's the only thing i'm saying
belichick is trying to say listen i took
a chance on you okay
and listen without your drive there's no
way we went six but still somebody had
to pick you even though nobody believed
in you at that time and i picked you as
a starter
i i think it's a beautiful thing listen
to me i think brady when people talk
about brady versus jordan
greatest athlete it makes no sense i
mean the guy's got a vertical leap of a
six-year-old he's not going to be able
to jump that high okay he runs the zero
to 40 yards
right so not a good look but it's not an
athlete but i'm going to tell you
something here when they took the heart
that nazi biscuit no it's one of the
recent ones
they took the heart and they saw he was
in the 99.6 percentile right the horse
he wasn't the biggest
just go to the top of
uh uh kentucky there will be winners
secretariat not secretary no it's
another one what's the horse's name kai
the go to
go to a horse winning uh
uh uh
not secretary go to horse winning
kentucky derby
uh winning kentucky derby at the names
i'll i'll tell you exactly what it is uh
somebody probably putting it down here
right now what the name is but anyways
when they talked about this horse um
they said the guy had a heart
a massive heart that was going to win
just go to all of them buddy i don't
know why you're yeah just go to all of
them we'll figure out what the name is
in a minute here anyways the point is
this guy's got a heart of a champion
american pharaoh is who it is american
pharaoh
uh he was not the biggest
he was not the fan he was he he was not
the fastest not the strongest not the
biggest he didn't look impressive but
when they measured his heart you know
they bought him for like five thousand
hours you know that horse was bound for
like five thousand dollars or fifteen
thousand dollars you know his stud fee
alone is three hundred thousand dollars
per stud fee
okay so
you know that was on brady but somebody
believed in him
and uh credit goes to both of them and
the the league will miss them although i
think the nfl is right now stacked
with a lot of great
talent that's going to take this league
for sure make it exciting for another
day i just hope that he does not
go away meaning i hope he does what you
know peyton manning has done
has done and even drew brees and the
legends and just still be a part of the
game but he'll do it his way he'll do
that as he should he's not going to do
it like the other guys to me i don't see
him playing as big a role as those guys
just his personality isn't really that
that type of commentator you know
analyst like he's just not that that
dude you know but
i agree i hope he does i just
is there a bigger stud
in
in the world oh what i was gonna tell
brady i was gonna say i didn't make my
point i'd say he's the greatest athlete
of all time he's the greatest winner of
all time yeah he's the greatest one of
all time listen when you play against
somebody else michael jordan you play
finals you could have a bad day the
knicks could beat you first game when he
played against the knicks in the
playoffs that means he would have been
out of the playoffs if it's only one
game
but this guy you have one game and you
win seven at it what is a seven seven
out of ten yeah that's insane you do
that and the argument is always from the
giants fans eli beat him twice yeah did
you see what uh eli said eli said i just
want to sit there and say i think i'm
uniquely qualified yeah because
i watched you win when i was in college
in super bowl then i played against you
and i watched you when i was in the
league then i watched you win a super
bowl after i retired and he used the
words he says you were gracious enough
to let me win too
correct
yeah
no
his biggest foils were the manning guys
he had to go through peyton manning
every year and batman had to go through
him and the the two super bowls that he
lost other than philly was to eli
manning and people had to literally
catch balls on top of their helmet yeah
in order to beat tom brady you had me
back to the goat
you had me at catch balls
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye